can you hear good can you see how you
see us are we live is YouTube working
prop oh my goodness gracious
are we live maybe's tell us if we're
live can you hear us again please tell
us Oh Tosh Cooper and Jen Smith I see
y'all are already having a conversation
I like it
god I don't know what happened man we
were in the middle I was starting to get
my my flow it only takes me like 45
minutes get it flow you know a quick
warm-up guy yeah and then all sudden
we're watching we got like 115 viewers
and then it went right down to zero and
I was like I think it's just a glitch on
YouTube let's just keep acting like
everything's fine and then suddenly
YouTube shut down and I was like ah [ __ ]
red warrior send me this pop-ups
commercial sell so [ __ ] all right but to
be fair we're gonna be doing our normal
routine we do have a separate stream if
you guys can please hit that like button
was in the middle of that stream I was
like you know honestly it's been a
pretty smooth week it's a things have
been going pretty according to plan and
then suddenly everything melted of
course that's the way it works right
opportunity makes with difficulty if we
happen to crash again you know we'll
just keep doing this through this is
right we have some super chats that we
definitely did not get to so we're gonna
make sure we get to the super chats
we're gonna super chat right back at you
we will make sure to get to them but
yeah let's let's start going through
some of them I'm gonna be hopping around
this is the overall general theme of
today's livestream appreciate everyone
who is hopping back in here you have no
idea how much of a panic attack that was
for me we thought it was our fault
Anisa Instagram called us and I was like
what's happening like what gives at
least the crash wasn't that long got
text from a few friends who are like
guys you to my brother texted me and
everything anywho thank you let's pick
back up some of these again I want to
make sure we honor them I don't want
people who's super changgil the one from
a few minutes ago that when that crashed
I want to make sure they feel honored so
the first one that we missed we gotta go
above Britney Britney Lange Britney
Lyons said hey guys how's it going good
the shows that I've been watching his
friends and re watching The Witcher and
on Disney Plus the Mighty Ducks saga
well thank you Britney Lange fun fact I
answered all this in the last live
stream when YouTube was down so I went
around to this answer just for you
Brazilian draft even better than the
first friends in the end rewatching for
which her and the Mighty Ducks are gone
Disney well friends is my favorite show
of all time so I'm glad you're keeping
up with that Britney Lang love your new
profile pic change the other thing too
is what did you say you've been watching
a Witcher that's pretty impressive
considering the fact that it's a brand
new show fairly brand new and you're
already watching it I don't know too
many people who have actually started a
new show and then rewatched it
immediately I usually like to give it a
bit of breathing room before moving on
to the next one
I like to start real watching before I
finish this series so that like when I
had time I'm reaching the last season
I'm already part way through the third
season mmm really doubling up this is
already a smooth oh my god
[Laughter]
little Antonio that can be attributed to
the Internet alright so what else do we
got in this chat right here that you
guys are talking about here well I got
my shirt I don't know where I got this
shirt from what's funny is I got an
extra large of this shirt and then I got
a large when I lost weight it's the same
shirt I got this from from DT merch calm
so total DT merch calm and get that
toasty goodness all over your body if
you guys can make sure to hit that like
button that would be great because yeah
we were doing good we were almost the
200 people attend nope did not happen I
have not seen that m'kay animated
movie yet mm-hmm I have not but we'll we
will get to it but I will get to it
Thank You cetera free thank you everyone
who's been hitting that like button
because we need to recover from what
happened the last livestream yeah we got
to upload this all over II know we did
not lose our old super chats we are
going through them right now I
screenshot on all them so I could show
them on screen that way we don't get him
mixed up with any new super chats that
potentially come in on this one all
right so moving up movies and shows you
watched her in quarantine you know what
else I've watched what's that you know
what else I've watched what's here I'm
in suspense now I mean because you
you're efficient you know and you've got
a broad taste so I'm like what a Greg
watch that it was interesting I thought
it wasn't good boys cuz you already
talked about good boys better call Saul
oh really caught up on better call Saul
and you know what that show I think is
just as good as Breaking Bad I'm just
I'm saying it a lot of people will not
meet me there but I think it's just as
good as Breaking Bad okay I mean I think
that there's an argument to be made from
the parts of it I've seen that's a
that's a reference to the last last name
from 30 minutes so go watch that what I
want to get what that callback and like
it and then you're like oh but joke that
was a comment if you actually did 1922
sequel to 1917 I and a lot I mean I
can't we're just gonna treat this as if
the live there's gotta be way to like
download those and then just upload this
as one long video and really [ __ ] up our
algorithm on YouTube yes because the
complete cut will get all the views I've
seen all of arrow by the way Chris and
this the chat is asking I've seen every
episode of arrow that ending was okay
daniel Jones my favorite scenes in
Jumanji the next level were the scenes
with Aquafina being game even mundo
random Andy's channel what's up dude you
were in our last livestream when you
were killing it yeah man
took a break from watching movies to
catch up on shows currently Bates Motel
I've only seen the first season agents
of shield the season has just started
season 3 I'm only on season 4
flash I finished all of arrow that was a
weird backdoor pilot they had on the
penultimate episode Gotham I'm on the
final season on patreon for Gotham dude
new girl that's a good show
I like the new girl who's lime well
don't they bring it back they did for at
least a minute there I haven't seen Andy
Griffith and and and double D I know
what you could be referring to there
dude got your nog Rafi
well dude those are some good shows man
your your thing on whose line reminded
me of another thing that I watched
during during the pandemic which is
still happening right there's anything I
watches during the pandemic literally
Middleditch and Schwartz hilarious
Netflix special long-form improv show
but with Thomas Middleditch and and
bench was named Ben short and Ben
Schwartz who voices Sonic the Hedgehog
force and it is hysterical one of the
funniest things I've seen hands and all
your oh and the other thing I watched on
Netflix
the Jerry Seinfeld stand-up absolutely
funny man really really funny stuff go
check that out that Jerry Seinfeld
stand-up is really funny wasn't never a
big fan of the Seinfeld show but I
really do appreciate his stand-up a hell
of a lot mmm guy thing else Jon I'm just
surprised love that Jerry Seinfeld
stannum because I know how much of a fan
of his you typically aren't what are you
talking about you know I thought you
didn't find his comedy and his coffee
show funny oh yeah I'm not a fan of his
like you know television series but I
really liked his stand-up Oh a lot good
really like a stand-up a lot I've
learned about your taste today all right
now you're seeing a surprising amount of
love for place below the vines which is
red dude Ryan Gosling a place around the
Pines is [ __ ] incredible mm-hmm Oh
Fargo the TV show that is also a good
call there's some heady shiz on there to
say is the least the king of Staten
Island trailer no not familiar with that
one oh wait that's a baa-baa movie
not a big Pete Davidson fan I like him
when I like okay I like it when he's
like the side supporting character in
those SNL sketches yeah not a big
generally speaking Pete Davis like I
tried watching a stand-up couldn't get
into it
usually when he's like the lead is
something I can't get into it I don't
mind his interviews I like him on uh on
like celebrity roasts videos though I
love celebrity roast videos you know I
will say I did on my one trip to New
York City I went to a stand-up show my
friend was performing in and he dropped
in and did a set he just dropped in
before the headlining the next show and
gave us a free set and you know he was
working stuff out but it was charming
thanks for being in Janeane Garofalo did
comedy she was working things out as
well this is weird I never been in this
part to LA I'm sure many people have
been through this and I've never been
through mm-hmm
we watched the first three episodes of
preacher Lewis I would love to finish it
Jarrod Barkley thank you buddy
do brat pack marathon st. how most fires
owner rated number 80s John I feel like
it has something on that thank you for
your super sad dude Jarrod Barkley I
love your thumbnail are you that young
because we can't advertise to you if you
are because III think that we would be a
great inspiration for you and I'm
looking to mentor some young children so
if you are that young it would be great
to talk to you in person
that's right start a really Jex
mentorship program that's changing young
lives good are we have you seen any of
these like brat pack movies John oh yeah
I mean I've seen The Breakfast Club
I've weirdly it's it's one of the more
like toward the end of it I think but
I've seen weird science a bunch of times
I've seen a few of them oddly st. Elmo's
fire is one of them's a weird science
yeah as in the John Hughes movie hmm
that's a brat pack movie well isn't it
at least Anthony Michael Hall and a lot
of those ensemble players are in that
movie I guess I count it kind of near
the hallway and I was think of the Rat
Pack know your options are like
really I was really confused right there
no no no the brat pack the brat panic
and we're back yeah and I you know I
like those movie I'd be curious to see
saying almost fire it's not my favorite
uh era but you know I like like the 80s
themselves generally yeah I mean I don't
share the same 80s nostalgia a lot of
people do but also just different
coming-of-age stories connect with me a
little bit more like they when I'm
watching them I always feel a little
removed from the time in place so I feel
like if you grew up during the eighties
they're prime for you but you know yeah
not to say that I dislike them but yeah
I've seen someone that you know in the
chat haven't seen a DC animated movies
I've seen a good amount of them actually
I have the DC Universe app I'm still
making my way through many of comics
over there oh yeah
gotta keep that nerd cred alive king of
the hill Niraj Krishna
thank you for your super chat dude buddy
he's watching right now uh and Niraj I
just love you buddy we got a special
shout out coming your way John wrote it
himself haven't read it but what John
writes always makes sense always really
great Ozark
kims was kim's convenience oh it's about
kim jeong-hoon running a convenience
store google it mine hunter oh yeah oh
yeah I've seen every episode of that I
love that show extractions great alter
to carbon my brother is a big fan of
that haven't seen the neighborhood James
Bond all the movies yeah damn dude how
do you have time to watch all this [ __ ]
there's so much you're making your way
through like a wide variety of things
right there yeah while it's running a
convenience store in Toronto members of
a Korean Canadian family deal with
customers each other and the involving
world around them that does sound fun
yeah I've been watching the bad boys we
got Michael and the chat saying been
watching the bag boys movies Anisa
dislikes all the John Hughes movies
mmm Mimi M has been watching wait go
back
just just just a little bit a little bit
because I was go to you yeah bad girls
wait where was that I saw it
damn never mind good girls there you go
you gotta watch bad boys and good girls
back to back dude we got some of our
show and the movies we got Jen Smith in
the chat right now we got lb in the chat
right here
he wasn't even all clerks I do like the
first clerks quite a bit yeah Daniel's
saying he could beat me in Mortal Kombat
11 I don't think so I don't think you
can do once you beat him that's just
gonna charge him up to destroy you
understand when I play video games I'm a
cocky son of a [ __ ] like when I'm
winning
I am so annoying I am the worst person
to play video games would because I
really rub it in your face and then when
I started losing my mood just shifts and
I know this is a terrible quality about
me I become a total [ __ ] in like a
cold way I don't just like I don't like
start belittling you or something I
Bluto you when I'm winning but when I
lose the mood in the room just changes
I'm a terrible place I become this like
a complete like different person when I
play video games I'm not a fun person
yeah I would love to do some less place
I feel like I feel like that would be
miring when John starts beating me too
if John starts beating me in a video
game is not happy I just start thinking
of like oh you're just such a privileged
white boy like that's where my mentality
[Laughter]
is solar opposites good Kyle Kyrie Kyrie
Joe I would love to see it I'm a big
Rick and Morty fan Nancy Nancy back in
our live stream happy happy and then
staying with my parents through this oh
that's nice s what is that what does
that mean shout out shout out to Mike at
bucket miss oh good what a cute name
well I have one cat called [ __ ] it and
we're watching Murder She Wrote Columbo
in Midsomer Murders together over some
TV classics I haven't seen any of this
[ __ ] you're watching and
I've seen a left out I've seen a little
bit of Columbo because a you know TV
Land and me TV runs a lot of my home but
I appreciate you contributing to her
super chat my dear you know what you
know oh I you said midsummer muck murder
night so I reminded me so the other day
it was kind of early when we wrapped up
and there's still some sunlight outside
so I was like you know what I'm gonna
watch a movie I'm just gonna watch an
episode of television I'm gonna watch a
film and I was like I have not seen
midsummer yet
I'm gonna watch mid samar but it was so
bright outside and there's so much
darkness in the beginning of that movie
that I was like I can't watch this of
all this glare so you know what I'm
gonna watch good boy good boy
you know that's how my taste and variety
changes just like so I wanna watch this
like weird horror movie or I want to
watch this sex comedy yeah here's what
you do you start midsummer you know you
watch the part you watched at night and
then once they get to Scandinavia then
watch during the daytime that's a good
call yeah as a there is a lot of bright
in that movie too mid Samar's a mindfuck
accord in this chat it's a yeah all
right let's see what else in the chat
everyone's saying they've been
rewatching lately or watching for the
first time you know be fun if you guys
specify in the chat which you've been
reading or what you're you'd watch for
the first time like samuel saying he
watched Breaking Bad for the first time
it was lucky I wish I could be there for
that experience
no to live vicariously through something
like when I love something yeah and I
introduced it to my girlfriend I love
being there for that feeling of just
because if she's into it if she's
freaking out that stuff I feel like I'm
I'm really really
that did not go that way for children to
men she was not into that that was like
oh this is what it's like when you don't
like one of my favorite movies this is a
bummer of a feeling
because then it yeah then it almost
makes you kind of bent out of shape a
little bit because you know your
enthusiasm and your love gets a little
yes mushed yeah then I was like well
you're not getting any sex tonight then
lady first man in history to use that
car cuz she's always craving sex for me
she's always like can't get a Greg give
me the D and I'm like not now I'm tired
like oh I've had a long day everyday
she's begging tenacious fior everyone
knows I'm being sincere this is how my
real life goes John why are you always
reading your text messages when we're
streaming it's so unprofessional
apologize and this is I've worked my ass
off to make sure this is a real
professional live stream just like
talking about how my girlfriend wants
the deal to D stop ruining the lack of
you're making this really unprofessional
D really sorry guys when you're not
present I'm not present oh you're the
leader
I hate now and I watched Keanu just
recently oh you did and we'll get to
Lois is super chat in just a minute whoa
tell us about Keanu Keanu is the key and
field movie and it's funny because I
don't remember exactly how everyone's
feeling when it came out but I feel like
there was this expectation for it to
like reinvent comedy true um which you
know it doesn't necessarily but you know
it's still a really fun movie and it's
still highly enjoyable I love the George
Michael bits all that you rubbing your
mustache during my monologue
oh this is funny for people you know
gonna yes and I know they but they could
have a good we like to people in this
live stream who might get that joke I
can build a live stream inside joke
build it you try to tend to everyone in
the life hey whoever's here make sure to
hit that like button by the way
apparently that does something for live
stream yeah man we've already got 86 on
this live stream alone can we get can we
get to a hundred likes while we're live
never happened in the history of the
real rejects as I never encourage people
to do it but I'm occur
today do it louis Burrage love that name
dude louis barrage there's a compliment
for the day I've watched more TV than
movies during quarantine did you guys
ever watch community it's now on Netflix
in the UK and so I've started my third
playthrough congratulations Louis yeah
you you've seen community right I have
seen all of community but I add see I
have seen a good amount in the way that
one who's watching a show witness
alright guys so here I'm a big fan of
the show Louis based off of your
suggestion based off of your super chat
I'm gonna tell you like real-life
annoyances I had living with John here
Oh God
so I felt very entitled don't worry John
if I tell a story about you being
annoying it's really about how I'm an
[ __ ] let's remember that okay sure
might make you look bad so when he moved
in I had the there's a TV I bought I I
had it mounted in everything and so
naturally and I was living by myself for
a long time before he ever moved in and
99 percent of the time what was playing
on TV was my selection it was something
I chose to play but then every once in a
while John I mean like we never had we
would never be like hey dude you want to
choose something tonight cuz we didn't
like watch it together because we've
already like filming together all day
and editing together all day that we
were like let's just go to her separate
rooms get away from me yeah and there
was one kitchen too so that creates a
tandem yeah thing is whoever sits down
first
so just as a reminder for just tuning in
Louis was asking if you watch community
and the only time but then we would
never run it by each other if one of us
was just gonna watch the TV and 99
percent of time it was me who watched
the TV now I never watched community
because I was so annoyed with John
because he would randomly at times just
lay on the couch and then turn on
community when I wanted to watch TV oh I
didn't know how to just be like yo dude
is it cool if I choose something
so my association with the community to
watch the show I wanna watch and John
just shows yeah now you get how I felt
when The Cleveland Show
king of the hill and so I would be like
man it's maybe you okay let him watch
one episode right and then he would just
let it play and you just keep watching
the next episode in the next that's a
Sara Lee good show television after all
that 70 shows I want that is my
association I really hope you never
started yeah yeah hey we hit a hundred
three likes yeah can we get 210 yeah we
get to a hundred and ten likes I think
that's the thing we got to keep these
really manageable what jab eco is in the
chat pod Abbi why is audio the stream
caught my underwear oh wow really that's
a that's that's enough to get us the
yellow dollar bill right there let's
risque I'm not in my underwear
oh goodness sorry I was both looking at
your underwear and reading a comment
about Atlanta Greg saw if you guys
haven't seen Greg saw Oh throw a like on
that video look if I'm telling a story I
can't be looking at the chat at the same
time because because I'm gonna lose
straight of my oh [ __ ] what was it sock
that's what happens when I'm reading at
the same time all right let's just keep
this chat over here keeping it over here
high five hundred seventeen likes oh
this is incredible thank you guys
really appreciate it oh can we do 125
keep adding seven every time we should
encourage people to hit the like button
in the most unenthusiastic can we get to
2,100 2530 hundred 30 likes 3,500 525
like Twitter 10 20 likes
alright let's see here rewatch king kong
2005 you know that that movie I feel
like it like is one of those epics that
almost gets there and and like it's
memorable for that reason yeah almost so
much depreciate fever boat thank you so
much for your super chat dude I just
watched serenity 2019 today I can't wait
we can't oh man I can't tell you a story
about this one wait till Friday on the
Schmo down we've had some excellent
career some big collabs this week on
poorly made movies are sort of like
comfort movies for me because they are
often entertaining on a metal level well
hey I got a fever vote hey oh my god hey
yeah a fever boat thank you for your
super chatting yeah I absolutely agree
with you sometimes I prefer to watch a
bad movie like a poorly made move that
was up JA sorry I just want to point out
you work doubly clever because also that
movie has a boat in it
look at that serenity 2019 Matthew
McConaughey the boat
how was I doubly clever because you your
reference you made a book you read their
name and then the boats is in the name
and I was like oh gosh yeah bring a
comment back I can mix this is a last
livestream I don't know what John talks
about Dominic I noticed you in the
livestream don't you worry buddy what is
final space and what's a chickadee puck
I love seeing that in the chat let's see
here watch the original Doctor Dolittle
with Rex Harrison man the the pics that
are in this chatter look I'm just gonna
do a speed round of everything I'm
reading in the live stream right here of
the movies that people are listening
Barban Fink
1991 Willy Wonka and the Chocolate
Factory
Shrek venom 2
Rasik world there we go Argo How to
Train Your Dragon train your dragon I
can't see anything cat what does call me
cat the things the things that you guys
are choosing to watch right now are so
damn entertaining Orgazmo I can't I
can't see a linkage to any of them from
dust so Shawn is a pretty great show I
appreciate you pointing that out dude
mmm balls of fury I'm glad for visiting
that let's see here what do we got all
right
fever Patrick Pacheco Peter Coe Peter
Pacheco thank you til haven't learned
that accent we are watching the full MCU
timeline who's who's the full MCU
timeline
who's week inclusive of TV shows one
shot Netflix shows and movie that is a
great [ __ ] way to make use of your
quarantine dude to do the proper
timeline animal you the full package not
just the the the movies but to include
the one shot and and the all the TV
shows and all the shows that don't
matter them see you comic ever written
about any of the character I mean I feel
like that'd be pretty for that that does
make for a fun time and does give you
the full package experience so I respect
that a level of respect that level of
commitment especially knowing how
inconsequential some of them are gonna
be cough cough Netflix shows but hey I
hope that overall you're having a fun
time with it and Peter thank you so much
for your super chat dude and then moving
on that guy Cary you guys should watch
justified one of my favorite shows I
love Timothy Olyphant and Walton Goggins
I love Watson Goggins I feel like he's
not a pervert and margo martindale i
definitely a pervert but walton goggins
definitely not a pervert okay okay David
Thewlis David Thewlis is definitely a
pervert Oh guys tell me in the chat
actors who you suspect might be perfect
the whole topic I'm not talking about
people who have been in the media I'm
talking about people like you look at
them and you go there's something about
them that I just get a vibe that they're
that they're probably a creep in real
life okay David Thewlis Peter Sarsgaard
okay okay Ryan Reynolds this should have
been the topic for today who's a creep
which actor do you think is the perfect
Kevin J Nevin chain Donald Trump we
already know we already know oh this is
great Cebu [ __ ] yes you chamois
definitely Nicolas KITT Michael shed and
yeah I could see it Michael Shannon's
one of those actors who I love but I'm
like you creeped me out dude yes
Daniel day-lewis no joke I had a dream
yesterday that Daniel day-lewis was at
some film festival in Italy that I was
attending M night Shyamalan was wrote
this down at my turtle today M night
Shyamalan was introducing me to Daniel
day-lewis I made some crack he got very
defensive as if I wasn't respecting his
process and then I woke up your stories
never make that mistake you know miles
tell I could see miles teller yeah
absolutely creeper Tom Hanks come on
this is the most interactive the chats
all been is I should've shouted the
sound it should have been today's topic
I've heard Danny DeVito is an incredibly
sweet man
Jackie Earle Haley yeah probably a creep
Crispin Glover we already know we
already know Christmas Carly Sheen we
already know all the skarsgård Catherine
I feel like just being on True Blood
counts miles teller yeah Mel Gibson how
dare you your dad know he's a creep
definitely creep Michael Cera
Michael I could see Michael Cera
secretly being like a [ __ ] nurses
were just like really kinky James Franco
we know Jack Nichols Jack Nicholson is
like a charming creep yeah he's he's a
creep by design and we're okay Willem
Dafoe absolutely a thousand percent
Dafoe yeah yeah he's he's got a feud
with Kristian harloff
Greg Alba Greg Alba Jared Leto Greg Alba
everyone know that everyone knows
Eggbert take that back everyone knows
Greg Alba is easily the biggest creep in
real life right person on Pine star if
you've watched one video the real reader
you know Greg outlet definitely creeped
in real life but who's creepier Greg
Alba or Crispin Glover oh crap Craig I
was deaf I see Crispin Glover where's
creep on his shoulders
see there's a major difference there I
feel like we can get as 125 likes can we
get to a hundred and thirty-three lights
I love that number thank you guys
hitting that like button Thomas Jane Joe
bide oh Joe Biden definitely all
politicians Vin Diesel yahoodi Dench Oh
Judi Dench she's like foreign real-life
creepin Anthony Hopkins masturbates in
public Eisenberg guy Pierce loves to
crap on people's check these are all
true stories I'm telling you guys all
true stories ash I support all true
stories Christopher Nolan yes definitely
creep um make it stuff film Jimmy Fallon
Jimmy Fallon's fake life makes me very
uncommon being in the same room with it
though Oh John Goodman Oh God I would
hate for him to be a creep in real life
like how Billy Bob says women women are
creepy but Oprah's especially next
question do you guys think Ellen
DeGeneres is a fraud why would we think
that because I've come across many
videos that are saying that oh good well
we should research further all right Tim
Blake Nelson that's a deep cut Deonte
wim Wimbush thank you for your super
chance you might pronounce your name
right Deonte wit that's every live
stream right there that's every live
stream I just did that for you deontic
am i pronouncing this right ten dollars
excuse me I'm putting your name that's
fine excuse me from butcher your name
what's the question
I've watched birds of prey bumblebee
detective Pikachu and up all for the
first time rewatched the jungle I love
that movie the jungle is a great film
rewatched Finding Nemo yeah Oh God that
independent dramedy about a dad who lost
his son in the middle of World War two
on with the deformity and his best
friend with amnesia
very good food war with my oldest
daughter her first time okay wait real
question you said Yuri watch Finding
Nemo oh I thought I thought he was
saying here II watched Django Unchained
with his daughter good
you know she does not about that kid
life all right she wants those Tarantino
joy well I appreciate the super chat
dude and you know what we like birds of
prey you hate us if you want but we're
at a hundred forty one likes oh hell
yeah go for one forty eight bumblebee
thank you guys are eating the like
button bumblebee
love that movie you know I heard Travis
Knight is not returning for the
follow-up transformers felt I've heard -
it's a bummer detective Pikachu that was
okay up Ed Asner family friend of Ed
Asner voices coral in that movie family
friend of mine as good to replay love
and shout out breath super funny guy
real-life Jango might be my fan still
Kill Bill
Django's Mardon my second favorite
Tarantino movie I'll never forget the
the like new Beverley shows they would
do for that with like these crazy-ass
Hammer trailers right now do i cartoon
never forget that either John I'm sorry
you should have gone well you didn't
invite me because you'd like to do
everything by yourself
or unless someone invites you but you
don't know how to pick up your phone be
like hey Greg I was just watching
community but Michael I hang out me once
communities done
oh you know what else I've watched
during this quarantine time is Christie
Elias stand up and there's a chunk in
there like a ten-minute chunk that I saw
him do live because comedians will test
out their bits at like The Comedy Store
or The Improv and I saw that bit live
like 10 minutes of it is hilarious but I
didn't really find his special all that
funny and Christie Ellie is one of those
stand-up comedians who I think is just
way funnier when you're there yeah you
know I was like an energy in the room
kind of kind of performer now the last
question I throw out said the chat was
do you guys think Ellen is a fraud let's
see what the chat has had to say Ellen
should pay her staff Mimi says ah that
is true yeah Gabi is saying Ellen is a
fraud didn't really write using both
back Jacob is saying no Ellen is great
people are always looking for a reason
to take people down looks like the
conclusion
people think Ellen is a fraud mm-hmm TM
is saying Ellen ain't [ __ ] oh damn look
out guys hit the like button if you
think Ellen's a fraud if you think Ellen
is not a fraud make sure to hit that
like button daniel Jones is saying Ellen
is mean it's too good to be true
Ellen threatened my grandfather never
get more interaction with these random
questions ask me anything all right okay
but I'm gonna go on to the next Super
chat at but in the meantime I want you
guys to tell me are you mad are you
are you mad at Robert Pattinson for
refusing to work out during the Batman
do you think he's just being sarcastic
do you think it's being blown out of
proportion how much spit has hit your
face because of this let us know tell us
do you think do you think complaints bad
complain to us Anissa Anissa how you
doing dear and now you know how you're
doing off-topic question but do I listen
to tame impala or Tokyo Police Club
there are some my favorite artists so
wondered if you all have checked them
out well Anissa I appreciate your super
chat dear tame impala John is a huge fan
John give a quick review of tame impala
go for it I guess I am a fan of tame
impala there they definitely have some
nannies that I absolutely love there's a
lot of stuff on loner ISM I think is
really good and I have heard the new
album in full I gotta listen to current
some gigantic currents is taking me
weirdly I know it's like a Rhodes
favorite tame impala album it's taking
me a little bit to get into that but um
yeah you know I enjoyed their sound you
know I like when they I wish they would
bring some of those guitars back but
that's just me well is elephant just
such a righteous tune and I feel like
since that album especially they have
just dropped the guitar out but yeah I
liked a impala I don't know as much of
Tokyo Police Club I'm sure I've heard
one or two of their songs I couldn't
identify one for you
Oh Tokyo Police Club they're great
they're a k-pop group in Japan both of
these facts
I'm sorry Nisa I don't know we you don't
care here for me here from jawed and
she's got a follow-up here thank you and
ISA appreciate you
double-teaming it also good yes Oh
rewatching all the screen movies as well
which one do you like best
my favorite is the first one because I
love Skeet Ulrich and it's the best you
do max my girlfriend was like jism last
time we were watching scream all the
risky I think we ski I didn't realize
how hot this Skeet Ulrich guy was until
until like I was rewatched at the last
time like [ __ ] he overs is like the
parents a really sexy guy but what I
remember from Skeet Ulrich is some
random movie that was on one day that my
dad was watching where Skeet Ulrich was
sitting on a toilet having a
conversation with someone don't know
what that movie was but that's what I
think of when I think it's good all this
is foreign Blantyre he's the Johnny Depp
who aged better yeah totally but I would
say the screen movies I my favorites my
ranking are exactly in the order they've
come out three four like 100% it's that
order I think qualitatively speaking I
will absolutely agree with you though I
haven't seen screen for although just to
be fun
and because I do in a cheeky way have a
soft spot in my heart for it scream 3
all right for that one so thank you and
ISA for those questions um thank you for
your contribution to the super chat so
so mm-hmm
the last question I asked the chat was
and this is very confusing for people
who are just tuning in we got to 150
likes 150 can we do 157 always up by 7
it's attainable thank you guys there's
so much this is fun I love you tonight
more p.m. like this then are actually
watching it
credible that's good thank you guys all
right so so my last question was um do
you guys think on the front and now my
next question was what do you think
about this whole robber pants and
refusing to workout let's go to the chat
and let's see what people are saying you
know what I got a different idea of how
we can do this I got a different idea I
got John I got a different idea let's
hear about it hold on
how come it's okay alright well show you
guys what we're looking at oh I hit the
wrong button
this one yeah and then you're gonna win
it switch to this one alright how it's
not showing John will change the window
how do I do that John hurry hurry we did
it stressful for YouTube crashes alright
let's see what everyone said don't worry
we're going in order of everyone's super
chest I see some super chats are here
but let's see here
are you back on your phone texting again
verifying a piece of news yeah is it
serious
no no no what the related you could
scream five texts about scream five I
wouldn't care but since it was Wes these
are so funny
alright so the last question I asked
finally getting to it is what do we
think about the whole thing with batted
Pattinson saying he's not working out
okay around that portion okay Pattinson
is being sarcastic it was bad they
casted him he's just making it worse
unfortunate damn Eric horsemen here in
the chad we'll get to your super chat
thank you buddy
okay i guess it depends on how fit
Pattinson already is I wish he would
would to help develop the character he's
playing I can't play in Pattinson for
now working out he should work out
quit the role it seems like this is a
really divisive topic is yeah damn it's
very divisive I fall in the direct
middle I'd sound like he's gonna be
gaining weight he's barely eating
anything
yeah he's just making his weird cheese
noodle towers he should work out for the
Batman or quit now I'm I really do think
he's probably just being sarcastic guys
yeah a certain extent I feel like he's I
feel like he's doing some
self-deprecating humor but I don't think
it's like I don't think it's as bad as
he's making it sound like like I doing
[ __ ] the day is gonna be fit and the
movies gonna be the movie it needs to be
and if his body isn't right by the time
they go back to brush and you can bet
something's gonna happen about that
so yeah it's true you know all right oh
we're at a hundred fifty nine likes
think can we get to 166 all right what's
another controversial topic that we get
um oh okay I got a fun one for you
should Amber Heard be fired from Aquaman
- oh that's a great quick in with the
chat in a little bit while we take care
of some super chats here where my should
Amber Heard be fired from Aquaman - and
recast in Grunewald - and should
fantastic piece should they replace zoe
kravitz with Amber Heard fantastic you
know they should cast her as Jack
Sparrow and then they should be Aquaman
all right all right all right okay I
gotta go to that one Ethan Holgate thank
you dude but it appreciate your super
chat I watched the good the bad the
weird awesome movie and a lot of candy
movies one of my favorite King Solomon
mine's goofy and from dusk till dawn
season one what's the good the bad and
the weird the good that is oh oh damn
wasn't it made by the guy who did
Shaolin Soccer I want as long as you
don't get in your [ __ ] phone again
it's a Western inspired
Hong Kong film I think I think it's like
a martial arts Western of sorts that's
also kind of kooky and zany that's the
best of my vague recollection well those
are some good picks you got here even
Holgate even though I haven't seen
anything except from dusk till dawn
season one underrated you know we
actually Ethan Holgate you're gonna like
this piece of news I interviewed Oh God
I know it's thick my place of friend why
am i blinking the cowboy wasn't the gun
[Music]
Jesse Garcia the cowboy the Ranger
cowboy from dusk till dawn Jesse sat
across from this man and spoke with I
was nervous to talk because I'm a big
fan of that show now I interviewed him
we shot that blum houses studios yeah we
did it for the channel if you're
interested go find that video just type
in real rejects Jesse Garcia
Big D energy and you'll find it you'll
follow there was a lot of D in that room
that day Anissa live-up also does BFF
Eric know about today's live stream he's
in the days and the live show now here
he's here ripping on Ellen it's a good
thing we did a part too or else you
wouldn't be here and then we'll say one
more Super chat I mean we got plenty
more to go through but I'm gonna go
check in with the chat remember chat
should Amber Heard be fired from Aquaman
dose Melanie Melanie I think Melanie is
that rare case who prefers me alone male
demographic Levi only let's take it
don't know why I did this to myself but
I've been watching that woman and now
love to hate it the family this is my
sexy voice so people are in the grades
are so happy alright alright here we go
we got it don't know why I did this to
myself but I've
watching bat woman and now love to hate
it the writing is terrible and it
disgraces everything Batman if you like
it more power to you air overs about to
die thank you for your super chat uh
yeah you know I watched I've seen Ruby
Rose
mm-hmm my god this is a good break can't
wait for my upcoming showdown Jesse
Garcia I watch the Ruby roads in some of
the crossovers yeah and then I realized
she's fine
definitely don't care to watch her bat
woman though in terms of a focus central
lead I could really feel like as a
supporting role with some little
appearances I'm totally cool with you
but it's wrecked but in terms of like
lead of the Batwoman
I just I just know I wouldn't be into it
I mean maybe it's like I'm assuming too
much but honestly I think I'm right and
I feel like the general feedback for the
bad woman show has only confirmed that
for me yeah
like I've heard an area positive word
said towards it I mean even Supergirl
has people who are like no Supergirl has
gone down in ratings a lot which I mean
honestly when a show goes down in
ratings during this time that is a bad
that is a bad sign
yeah so I say should we fire Amber Heard
let's go to the checked though it's the
other John okay all right so then John a
guy clickety click this button look at
he click there you go alright let's find
what people are saying about Amber Heard
should sheep everyone's still talking
about Ellen DeGeneres which is what I
really want Evil Dead series what about
alright let's go let's go let's go let's
go let's go let's go oh my god somebody
Connick oh my god somebody go okay I'm
trying to get to the point where it's
probably around the point where we
started hearing about it alright
Ellen had taken Patton's Azure I gotta
quit
I like it alright gta6 loved one
playable character Ellen DeGeneres yes I
dislike Amber Heard so much
oh damn replaced with Emilia Clarke
that's not a bad replacement pic oh and
a I mean that would give her a chance to
kind of reestablish herself yes she's
crazy if it was Johnny he'd be out very
true very tread is probably deceptive JK
Rowling was directing it or writing it a
lot it looks like there's a unanimous
yes
Palmer is another good call yeah Oh God
you know who else Chloe grace Moretz for
anything and everything everything every
role if Johnny tandyman
got fire from Pirates and Amber Heard
should be it's only fair very okay each
other's losses a movie hadn't asked if
China Depp is innocent if amber is fire
for being abusive other actors should be
blacklisted as well Oh looks like we got
a little bit of a controversial opinion
he's not stating that Amber Heard is not
abusive he is stating that if she's
fired for being abusive then other
people should be fired as well like
Ellen DeGeneres I knew is going recast
recast the Ellen show Ellen thing came
from the fact that all the sudden in my
feed like two days ago I'm seeing all
these videos about why Ellen DeGeneres
is a horrible person and just sent me
down a wormhole and I'm like is she
really there can with these new videos
or they just write algorithmically
showing up now Johnny Depp should be
Aquaman all that'd be great
I'm king of the Atlantis um I'm the
rightful heir to the throne oh man
Johnny Depp should replace it all right
Jen Smith just write her honestly I'm
not gonna lie I know for I know for
comics fans Mira is a very integral
character to Aqua
man I don't really remember that much
about what Amber Heard did in the movie
right red wig on and I've seen the movie
twice in the theaters and I'm still like
she didn't really make an impression
like the character Mira so I know she's
important but if she wasn't there if
they just did like some Ocean's thirteen
write-off thing of like this isn't her
fight and so you don't need to have her
in the movie there are a lot of other
planets that need saving
yeah but actually she was a pretty big
character in there she really helped get
Aquaman from A to B to C to D she did
yeah she really did help drive that plot
alright John come on what's her next
controversial question my next contra my
next controversial question on canceled
who you think should come back Jesus
sure there's a controversy that's not
fun I mean we'll do it but damn who's
buying the next six nine albums God
anybody alright where we leave off on
the super chat soon I don't know like
you put in this topic back on screen I
just re-watched a little princess which
is a very underrated Alfonso korone film
kind of like his Pan's Labyrinth oh
really yeah it's beautiful I featured
some early CGI but smartly used very
well drawn historical fantasy all right
where we at okay we got that wow we got
Gaea we did this one we did that one we
did our omelly
what's up ginger brand ready so just
started drag race UK also trying to get
into more horse stuff they'll hate jump
scares hello wow there's plenty of jumps
careless horror out there oh so is drag
race UK like a racing show yes they're
alike it's kind of like a ripoff of Top
Gear exactly
ah yeah a driving good show yeah that
makes sense and the competition is they
got a drive those cars and check them
out but also while wearing women's
clothes I appreciate you telling me I
mean
drag race UK gas or watch they're very
much into cars also congrats on your
Broadway Twitter love and also congrats
on getting a more horror movies dude
watch movies that are not based off jump
scares because those tend to be the
better horror film watch split because
Betty Buckley is in it
watch out jump scares in a drag race Jen
Smith says oh yeah there's a lot of
jumps jump scares and drag race
hey Alex done glad you're in the chat
buddy YouTube is down really comedic duo
I love your content oh thank you thank
you so much dr. Schwartz on dr. sparta
this is the comedic content you carry
this is a checkup
this is my favorite laugh guys this is
the best livestream ever reason why
we're at a hundred sixty-eight likes and
only have a hundred eighteen concurrent
viewers at the moment can we go for 111
down 115 viewers okay let's get to 175
likes I want the most odd like - viewer
ratio ever I want 600 likes
thank you guys so much alright so the
last question John throughout to this
stream who was cancelled that should
make it come back let's see if anyone
answered John's question okay let's go
here let's go let's go damn go don't
we're getting we're getting everyone's
super chat we never end a live stream
without game run super channel unless
YouTube decides to shut down in the
middle of us will be here until 10:00
p.m. going alright Rob Schneider for
Mira that's great stuff seen a lot of
mirror casting in here alright alright
no one's answering your question oh well
I just had it where to go someone said
louis c.k oh no really okay Jesse
Smollett I see really live stream oh no
but I actually watched Louie CK's
stand-up the one you have to exclusively
purchase for five dollars
you're part of the problem and it was
funny and uncomfortable taneous Lee I'm
just saying I I don't know how I feel
about it but I can't deny that I laughed
a few times and then I laughed a lot I
laughed a lot but there were some parts
I'm even really uncomfortable okay I am
a little bit of both it's important to
acknowledge these things that's how we
navigate in a mature world we say this
is what's awkward my main concern is
that $5.00 even the stream doesn't are
we behind of course we're behind
remember on time all right okay okay I'm
Way behind here all right okay okay
don't worry I'm ganna pjpk we got PJ in
the chest back I have been working from
home thank you for your super chat buddy
20 bucks is a lot thank you um I have
been working from home so I put
something on in the background while I
worked lately it has been survivor
Marvel and random movies as well also
watching the Michael Jordan documentary
dude dude dude John has a perfect
response for you I'm telling you PJ he's
got the fat that is repeated a tweener
or super Chet John has got such a good
response for you you're gonna feel like
it was worth contributing this super
chat once Johnny's the best response
you've ever heard now some people might
be like Greg must not have that good of
a response to go off your super chat and
that's why he's throwing it to John not
the case I just know John has such a
good response to John respond I'm PJ man
I would love to hear your thoughts on
the Michael Jordan documentary cuz I was
I was reading an article the man Ken
Burns really against it and he was like
you know you can't produce a documentary
about your own life so let me know in
the chat man was it was it worth it was
biased what was it like
that was good life-changing that was
life was good we're gonna move up thank
you by the way
Mimi M she has been watching during
quarantine Thank You Mimi M
miracle-workers insecure Seiken oh how
is hunters I'm tempted to start that
show up means fighting Al Pacino Jordan
Peele producer yeah I watch that show
yeah thank you for that recommendation
what else did you say I hear psych is
great and those are all I've heard all
those shows are wonderful secure is
great I've actually I'm behind on
insecure alright John look do you have
another question to throw to the chat
another controversial question something
that could be fun what reversal not not
freaky no not not not nothing topical
who killed Jeffrey ft okay how about
this if what movie if they announced
that they were going to release this
movie in theaters next week what movie
would it take to get you to go if they
said we're dropping this film in the
theaters and you're like well damn and I
have to see it it's that fun drama it's
that fun drama that's a fun drama okay
fun drama is what I said are you getting
a lot of responses never mind John did a
good suit
Ellen killed Epstein there we go streams
done we're gonna go back to those in a
minute
Ellen if she killed yo worse are what a
hundred eighty two likes thank you guys
so close that means a lot thank you can
we do 189 can we do a 180 383 - I see
183 183 like oh we lost like someone we
saw real time someone unlike doing how
it's probably area in the other so loud
I am retracting this like alright okay
where we at I am so off off base
mmm working from home okay Mira
coworkers next one Aneesa thank you
again hmm oh she's gonna tell us the
center stages Hey center stage center
stage the movie as well as one of my
faves
I've watched recent since it was the
20th anniversary that movie means so
much to me since I grew up as a dancer
reminds me of how much hello what did
you what did you study when you were
dancing like like pole dancing as a kid
is that what you did is your mom sarit
up the old dancing lessons so when you
were a kid um great exercise set I'm not
saying that cuz you're well if you were
a guy would it the same I'm saying
because I know you there's a difference
all right I don't say that to people I
don't really know cuz then that could
come across as offensive and throw me in
John's category of people who should
make comeback so you can cancel I'm just
answering you alright thank you for your
super check thank you so much my dear
thank you you're so sleazy center stage
CC you're one of my absolute favorite
people in the world undoubtedly we're
almost caught up on all the super chests
in the last the last question John
throughout to the chat was what John
what movie if they released it next week
would you go out and see in a theater
what's happening here I just need to
make that all big all right now mm-hmm
whoo what do we got Deadpool three
Avenger saw five did you ever [ __ ]
yourself we say show since it's already
here oh yeah I did yeah okay so if you
guys you guys would go to the theaters
now
during this time where it's still
dangerous for let's see it's Ellen a
quiet place to respect that movie
deserves to be seen in the theaters
especially during a dangerous time
spider-man 3 with Tobey Maguire yes
Wonder Woman 1984 venom 2 venom cats two
tenets which is undoubtedly gonna get
pushed if it dies it hasn't been
announced yet guys California stay at
home orders are they're a little bit
lighter because some businesses can do
curbside pickup now that weren't able to
open it all before yeah but it's got
push to July essentially it's still the
same [ __ ] you're not gonna wanna you
can't curbside deliver a film experience
all know it's a safe when I can go back
and eat at Denny's again not pick up
food that's my litmus test for safety
and society is Denny he's alright my
girlfriend wants to treat me to some
Denny's
that's really romantic and she's like
when are you gonna treat me and I'm like
crotch treat you will not date so
sausage all-you-can-eat breakfast guess
what you want all the time I clearly
have seen Christie Johnny Depp versus
Ellen the movie oh my god that would be
such a good movie
yeah Pacific Rim style if they're just
giant and they're duking it out or like
yeah she's Pacific [ __ ] ham Morbius
obviously but we never get you out
there's a lot of love for cats seriously
the New Mutants the New Mutants is the
one I'm really rooting for right now
yeah I'm rooting for them to actually
come out in August I love your answer
here James Bond sure James Bond if he
just shows up
it'll be good that would actually be the
perfect final James Bond title James
Bond yeah that would be good yeah the
perfect time to die a horror with you
guys in it okay go watch Greg song or
some of our old shorts now was your
surprise because anis is here saying 200
likes and Jon surprise oh snap wait we
don't have 200 concurrent viewers
oh that's what it has to be Jon we're
never gonna get there well do you want
the surprise now I have no faith well
every good ok well then well then do we
reveal surprise now or celebrate 200
likes and pick a different milestone and
do it next oh wait a minute no no 200
life so do that 200 likes
look chad is saying schneider cut is
what if they released that next week you
could say [ __ ] all singers and
condemning all go that would be the one
that gets me there i sack Schneider was
like uh guys I'm holding a secret
screening
Schneider cut this is the only time it's
ever gonna be shown oh they're only time
at you get elephants full scuba gear
he's good he's gonna [ __ ] everyone over
so many people are gonna show up for
that seriously man the Batman obviously
I don't think we're real people I mean
nobody's ever seen us outside of this
box here so you know that's true no
we're not even really friends this whole
back story that John and I have said
about like I ever knew George's first
grade total [ __ ] mm-hmm almost a to
hundreds
let's go down to 196 bjbj you've been so
freaking generous to us so kind to us PJ
London what does it stand what does PJ
stand for John insert you're great John
John has a great great acronym comfort
pandemic Joe thank you pandemic Jones
for your tribute to our super chat but
some of the many movies I have watched
on work wedding crashers all word is on
word I really hope more people watch it
you know like it this pandemic and the
stay-at-home workers hit right around
the time when onward could have had a
lot more traction and unfortunate didn't
wedding crashers I love that movie IRA
Mike my girlfriend hates those kind of
movies but I'm like no would you like
please ooh - ah but you won't do it but
my fine no more tea for you there's so
much withholding of your I know I
usually this is a weapon in this room
pal how you like me now Scott Pilgrim I
actually I own the DVD of it and I have
I don't remember it all I don't anything
I finished it so I want to watch it
Napoleon Dynamite Oh
just rewatched that yeah that's we spend
time we watching you're about to be an
inner geek imagine you're watching
before I knew dynamize before I do this
is like a week or two ago dope good oh I
need to see dope
don't be stopped by a vision system baby
driver and so you know what you're
watching some freaking uh [ __ ] Edgar
Wright movies you're huh inception and
yesterday I saw yesterday on the plane
ride to Colorado oh boy Oh what all
forty minutes of it how long is the
plane ride a car two hours oh really
really hour and a half well now you're
waiting on the Royal for a while
and then everyone was leaving the plane
and then the flight attendant please you
don't like five minutes left on this
[ __ ] movie please let me finish
and I'm I know what a main actor
yesterday he's a good actor he's a good
actor but the characters a nice guy that
is nice guy it's not cutting the
character annoyed me like that from
beginning to end he just got on my
nerves until like the last ten minutes I
guess that's the point but now he got on
my nerves okay and oh but thank you for
your super chat dude and just a take
thanks buddy so mustika what you're
missing is that clean guy really means a
lot bounces a little bit and and you
know does a cool motion to make us feel
cooler that's what you guys are missing
there Niraj krishna re-watched one of my
favorite graph that was actually gonna
be the theme of today originally which
was favorite comput movies I feel like
that tops and beaten to death or
probably get us the most viewers rewatch
road of perdition if you have not seen
road of perdition please to yourself a
favor and watch it thank you to Raj by
the way Coco great I was a mess if you
guys go to start us to find my Coco
reaction you will see me walking out of
the theater I've clearly been crying as
I start talking about it I start tearing
up some more walking down the steps
dan and all the hilarious film oh it's
not it's actually really sad movie but I
love those actors hell or high water or
how water under Jeff
your table Robert makes guys we have
completed something we have completed
two things we have come caught up with
the chat caught up on to the new to the
second stream caught up to the chat on
the first live stream first all the
first stream super chats that I'm
talking about baby
and John oh how many likes have we three
205 whopping likes now for weeks John
has been saying once we hit 200
concurrent viewers he's going to show us
a surprise
I had weeks insane ok Network 203 likes
let's he's been saying that right now
clearly we're not 200 users but we're at
206 likes now so we readjusted the rules
on the spot because John needs to make
some space and his Ridge backpack that's
right all right John what is this
surprise okay
so I honestly have no idea what the
surprise is that John has been teasing
for weeks and this better be [ __ ]
good okay so I've been going through a
lot of you know just my belongings a lot
of things in my life purging and whatnot
you know making space and updating and
in doing so I've found a lot of
keepsakes and a lot of things from the
past and one thing I found that I had
completely forgotten about
it's an old roll of developed film from
back in our old Taekwondo days oh sure
in this folder there are pictures of
young John and young Greg all the way
back in the DIA Wow and and yeah I
thought look look here's one right here
of there's a Greg Alva oh damn can they
see this look at that is Keeney is that
clear enough for you guys look at that
let's see John John alright here's what
we're gonna [ __ ] up the the focus here
put on the autofocus on the autofocus
all right now we just got a hold in
front of your face it's designed to find
faces this is not doing the trick hold
on you can kind of see it
John we have to manually focus John we
have to manually focus on John John John
John John look is that me that is you my
man's look at that look at lo in Gregg
oh snap yeah Oh Dan and what's this one
that is also us oh look I'm falling down
and there's no John's there John you
shall be kid in the center I'm a skinny
kid on the other side and her name was
Krisha I don't remember that woman I do
did you have a crush on her at the time
oh well knowing your luck now and she's
gonna find this live stream and be like
oh I heard you had a crush on me what's
funny is I had a crush on you too oh my
god uh John can-can you Pacific Rim me
always look at how suave young Greg Alva
looks there oh my god ki look here wait
oh snap
Oh young Greg oh damn I am a handsome
devil I'm a hands I look even better on
this camera out-of-focus
you're back in my John Cusack bed that's
young John before all that you see here
Oh God okay up there we were this is
John's crush that he had oh yeah I
remember she ran marathons or something
yeah or something and there's there's
the road the old man is there's Greg and
John with our friend young Oh
oh my god yes we used to choreograph
like fights together in the back of
that's unless you want to just show like
young Orson no no no let's refocus this
yourself focus it back on you let's go
to automatic focus and then switch it to
manual once the focus John do your
switcheroo
we did it was back in focus well thank
you John for that that was really sweet
of you was it an okay surprise John that
was really sweet of you you're welcome
I mean thank you can we get back to the
wife that was great dude that was great
what was the last question we threw to
the fans it was the one about going
outside all right which movie or did we
get a new question let's see what people
have said about the after showing them
the photos let's see how many likes
we've lost after showing you guys attack
I did tag one out for like 10 years
where were you like two years three
years two or three two or three years
Jonathan Taekwondo I got up to my green
double stripe oh got a tattoo of Ellen
all the topics of convergence all the
topics are meshed into one plane now I
would go out to see Ellen on cancel
Johnny Depp in the theatre that was a
good that was a nice surprise thank you
John I feel nostalgic so nostalgic yeah
all right you know here I'm gonna make
this fun I got an idea of a question to
30 you guys mm-hmm fun question to 30
you guys are they running that story
again about the Snider cut launching HBO
max I thought everybody said that wasn't
happening you're lying to us they're
lying
that's not a tight food oh damn Jerry
Bruckheimer unsure okay I need a I need
a fun oh okay well we should do to be
fair really fast actually just to be
fair we should we should actually catch
up on the super catching up from the
ones that happen when YouTube shut down
yes so now we're in the future we're
here in the future all right you got a
scroll who do we do Stuart oh my god I
think you just want to make that full
screen and then hit yeah all right
Jon's got this
all right look at that we're 209 likes
thank you guys
mmm Rizzo gaming we're so bad
now what Rizzo is talking about what
Rizzo is talking about specifically is I
mean is that uh yeah we really panicked
on the patron do that we shut down
temporarily while we were yeah yeah but
you do there's gotta be a way we can put
like a black box over this doesn't
confuse the [ __ ] out of me oh you can
just drop a window over top of it yeah
drop the other chat on top just make it
really small is that gonna work
boom boom diggity look at that all right
solution okay all right so have a third
person to do all this clicking okay so
yeah we were we were YouTube shut down
Thank You Ryan baby for the super chat
for that you didn't have to do that
preciate that am i sorry to make the
patreon disc or panic guys fall some
discord if you haven't done so already
Simulator songs fantastic musical
artists thanks for your super chat dude
say hi to Canada for me Brendan Vee hey
can we get more horror play musical the
ones brought away comes back I have no
idea what yeah I forget what you
actually sound like I'm sorry but I
remember the last time we said yeah you
said it was okay to do stereotypical gay
guy boys sorry just the way you broke
into that is halfway through the word
voice can we get more than horror played
musicals on Broadway comes back also oh
my god Hamilton Oh beat thee on Disney
Plus July 4th
yeah what's happened wait what's
happening they're they're premiering the
live performed like they have a recorded
live performance from I think the
original cast like when lin-manuel was
in it and everything and they're going
to let real watch it on Disney Plus yeah
wow that's so cool and so we can just
watch Hamilton on Disney Plus I guess so
[ __ ] yeah that's awesome if you don't
want to drop all the money or just spend
your entire life loitering for tickets
dude I am loving the chat right now
people have not stopped talking about
Ellen DeGeneres and they ever heard and
now them fighting each other this is the
best live stream conversation I've ever
seen you guys have dude there are so
many Ellen movies be them the mendel
Ellen Amanda Ellen case of elementary no
it should be John wick Hara Ellen oh my
god is so funny oh man oh my goodness
all right wait wait oh sorry all right
Ellen infinity war oh so funny what is
it happen this was the first question I
threw in the chat and and this is what's
been going on the fantabulous
emancipation of Ellen Ellen chapter two
I love those I would I would love to to
get famous enough to go on The Ellen
Show one day and talk about this day
with her and relay all the footage Ellen
I've heard you're a horrible human and I
got a live stream chat to prove it to
you let me tell you about Ellen age of
Ultron let me tell you about Ellen first
blood oh my god Ellen welcome to Ellen
covenant Ellen thar this is brilliant we
need to talk about Ellen just keep
throwing in comments about Allen
DeGeneres I honestly have no real dog in
the fight that's what I love so much
about this is I really have no actual
like qualms or like any actual I just
find it's so funny
I just hope Ellen does get to see it
sometime it is very confused shower
these super jab hearts go okay where did
that win to go when that when to go the
Windigo
in the meantime just to keep this a
little bit in synched doom-doom
doom-doom in sync
my girlfriend show me a samurai shampoo
shampoo it was a mirage champloo that
was a great one I'm trying to see well I
have a list of things I've
watched during quarantine watch all the
Austin Powers movies again I those still
really hold up Tiger King obviously oh
boy
whoa Johnson Wow oh I recently
discovered I'm pretty late to
discovering them but a chance some
channels I discovered during quarantine
the quartering discovered the quartering
I really enjoy his channel and geeks and
gamers too of listening to those guys
because they're not they're not like us
like there's so many opinions that they
give that I'm like I don't share that
opinion but I find them so entertaining
and not unlike I'm laughing at you way I
see why they're so successful and I see
what they do that's so good about their
presentation and there's geeks and
gamers and the quartering like they they
seem very genuine and they're coming
from a real place
and all of those they make great
arguments you know like and I I don't
disagree with them a lot either you know
but III really think that they're um I
really think they're great all right
that was a good plug they're sponsoring
this channel all right look there's iam
people all right okay I'm gonna we're
gonna do we're gonna do a speed round or
some of these super chests we take our
time with side of these super chests but
at the same time once we do some of
these super chats we're gonna be going
through and reacting to all these l
entitles you guys I'm looking forward to
doing that I'm really looking forward to
doing that hold on we'll do the super
chats in just a second I got an idea
John Mayer with over a second you've got
an idea bear with us for one second guys
I'd be it all right hold on you're
watching one seconds this is usually
where they would put up one of those
old-timey graphics which is like we're
experiencing some technical or whatever
but you know instead here behind the
curtain with us as we
go you know what I should do okay I have
an idea all right there is a black box I
think somewhere on the computer is there
yeah if you just search black box but
we're losing viewers by the second shiny
no we're only a 125 concurrent eyes
theory holds what is playing that's come
from the computer that's coming from the
computer yeah what's playing right now
yeah there's probably an ad playing on
one of the sites all right guys we're
gonna catch up on some super chats and
I'm we're gonna react to you guys Ellen
titles is uh sounds super funny hmm this
looks still pretty [ __ ] weird but
it'll do the job for now my bad
I'll try not to make this confusing
because there's two of us here all right
cool all right PJ did you lose your old
super chats I became a patron of you
because of YouTube crashing although I
have been meaning to no buddy thanks but
did not did not lose them we got you
right here but and I'm getting this [ __ ]
so organize it look how great I'm
sweating right now joining us I mean I'm
sorry it took a YouTube stream failed to
get that dude thank you for becoming
about so weird if you go in future and
because of that crap I mean I appreciate
it but but I think you'll like what we
have to offer on patreon especially for
the $5 rewards here which is what you
super chat here $5 the one we post the
most on there we would do a lot of work
on that what's here I've written you
entire self on the back for that one
Mike Watson thank you so much my friend
did you hear about the flash delay to
2021 that movies never gonna [ __ ]
come I feel like I heard it even though
I didn't she's never gonna come out any
flash news is not so wait I should get
rid of this [ __ ] too much I want
flash news is never gonna like it's not
even surprising anymore I'm just like
okay
yeah at this point it's been like all it
does is ghost so it's like I will we see
a flash movie at some point yeah I don't
think it'll be that soon though it
really bothers me that Ezra Miller has
not addressed at all the choking
incident that we're just letting that
get swept under the rug I mean from a PR
standpoint smartest move the guy could
do but it bugs me because it looks like
he attacked the fan it's in and I feel
like there's no like outrage about it
and like it's just like we got something
another rug yeah it was weird and
nothing ever concluded it it's just a
dangling thread I don't know maybe maybe
if they canceled Amber Heard they'll put
him in as mirror all right or them I
can't can't
that guy can't well thank you for your
super chat - yeah that guy Kari thank
you buddy
to answer your question from stream
number one it was my first viewing of
phase two and number three and I love
towel I also watched John justified it's
one of my favorites Wow your first
that's a can you guys imagine watching
the [ __ ] phase two and three for the
first time and doing it like like at
this Halloween after you've heard Ari
wait now I've got a word to say I mean
had you heard yeah where phase three
wound up because I feel like it's almost
impossible to have avoided that I mean
it's scary I mean like the way I can
identify with you that guy Keri is I'm
watching The Sopranos for the first time
and I just know it's a bummer it's
spoiled for me that oh yeah the time it
gets to the final episode it's gonna cut
to black I don't know how it's like how
can I enjoy the show now knowing how it
ends
then it's going to cut to put no other
details other than like I don't know
what happens episode I just know like
show some credits it's a famous famous
scene where it cuts the black and then
we don't know what happens but dude I'm
happy for you that you're finally able
to justified as a chef and watch for a
very long time very long time and
there's nothing to justify the that us
we haven't started it all right
random Andy's channel back in the chat
Aditi he said he was watching DD for
double dick
oh we got it wrong sorry about that
DeeDee as in daredevil facepalm I'm
definitely not giving any DeeDee if you
remember from previous life scenes I'm
old-school
hahaha that's right he's waiting till
marriage that's right that's good I
respect you and then Wade then once he's
in a committed marriage marital
relationship is gonna give her is like
then I could have a threesome most yeah
exhibition II fiend afterwards I waited
till after marriage and I've slept with
more woman than all my friends because
we let a lot of people in the better
this is the time to start don't do it in
high school oh man Thank You random
Andy's channel Thank You Billy Bob have
you two seen requiem for a dream I got a
story for you now I did see requiem for
a dream I was very much into Wayne's
were others the Wayans brothers the show
yes and then I was at the videos I we
used to get like mattify oh I think
might have been Entertainment Weekly
there was like a magazine that come I
was a little kid I didn't really know
like what adult [ __ ] was and so for like
movies and I watched and then I came
across an article about Marlon Wayans in
requiem for a dream I just assumed it
was a comedy
because Marlon Wayans is in it and then
I rented it and it I'm what I rented it
like the second it came out on on DVD so
I must have been at minimum 10 or 11
years old I was 10 or 11 years old when
I watched it and then all of a sudden
it's some very disturbing [ __ ] not funny
it's not a funny movie I do I haven't
rewatched it since the one time I saw
when I was 11
and yeah you think you're walking into
[ __ ] Wayans brothers kind of comedy
it turns into requiem for an aeronaut
sees a weird drug addiction movie yeah
I've seen it I had a friend in high
school who really loved that movie so I
saw it in high school
nah I wasn't led to believe it would be
a comedy but but I surely didn't laugh
at him guys we are at 219 lights thank
you so much so much we can get back down
to 200 I have a surprise just a sweet
200 number he really loves that wasn't
alright going up we got our biggest
super chat of the day mmm [ __ ] Eric
goddamn horsemen where do you work thank
you Eric my god I'm not even gonna read
your super chat that's how much it's
worth it I'm joking all right I'm late
as [ __ ] again freaking covetous oh you
got a co vid test super chat astir
result so what were your results that
have come back negative or positive
negative weight that [ __ ] episode the
office confuses [ __ ] out of me as I used
to know it right off the bat I'm like
negative or fun like well negative means
negative result is positive a negative
result means you don't have it positive
means you do have the positive result is
the negative news I don't want a pre-cut
pre to freaking show a movie that has
Ervin talking about just hey and a wave
up dude Eric that's so sweet of you
thank you buddy that's really sweet of
you thank you but do you tell me how
your results sy yeah did they did they
stick like a million mile long q-tip up
your nose I've heard it's really hurtful
I've heard it's yeah painful that's so
that's such a big concert beautiful
bliss whoo I feel like we've talked to
you before a beautiful bliss
thank you for your super chat the Lord
of the Rings movies what good what she
I'm assuming I mean is that sexist
because I'm assuming beautiful bliss as
a woman uh yeah that's basically what
that is I mean who's to say men or
otherwise can't be beautiful
break it just sounds like a thing a girl
would say oh my god it is the sexist
comment
okay mr. beautiful bliss I'm sorry I'm
sorry Lord of the Rings movies is what
you've watched her in quarantine all the
Star Wars movies the prequels that I
never oh wow he never smiles first time
once upon a time see you know honestly I
should have done what you watch does I
have an inner geek to match coming up
and I'm like ma'am my Lord of the Rings
Hobbit not a Harry Potter at all just
way off it's gonna be a great show am i
killing I'm gonna kill it'd be awesome
for the both of us thank you beautiful
bliss Jen Smith I have never watched
John wick should I start right now Jen
Smith I'm telling you watch it with your
little boy he'll love it
it's so will you that's right he's gonna
learn a lot of worthwhile lessons from
it that he's gonna want to recreate
right away thank you for your super chat
Jen Smith and beautiful place thank you
for yours I mean those are some great
movies to catch up on but Jen yeah watch
John wick [ __ ] be not seen John wick
watch that [ __ ] modern action classic
man
it's literally helped to at least sculpt
the current wave of action movies all
right guys I want to see I'm gonna take
a break from the super thank you for
everyone who's being a true to the super
chest has really been helping out a lot
especially during now when everything is
just in lockdown u2's broken and then
you know I said oh but last time we were
talking about the chat we wanted to see
we wanted to react to the titles that
people are saying in the chat of what
the ellen titles would be so turn in her
let's see what you guys have in the
store we're gonna scroll up there's some
beauties in here oh my god there's so
many we're not gonna do them all right
now we're gonna come back to this and I
want it I want it to oh man thank you
for all the super chests we will see
this there's so much this is about how
far we can scroll up yeah that's the
furthest let's scroll up monsters vs.
Ellen there you go Ellen Poole silent so
the Ellen Ellen king of the monsters at
man in the Ellen Ellen King yeah
at 41 hmm wonder wellen know it I love
especially when there's like a little
extra workings a word despicable Ellen
oh that's great
the haunting of Ellen's house Ellen I
think we just got another super chairman
of course and thinking buddy Michael
Pete don't worry when he gets yours I
just sent you a long-ass reply on
patreon 2001 in Ellen Odyssey Ellen gum
yes
that's my favorite kind of sequel title
Ellen hard to Ellen harder the Ellen
nice and simple
works for a wanna move Ellen the 13th
Ellen Dark Fae sorry that's gosh I love
this this is my favorite this is my
favorite you guys are amazing this is my
favorite thing in the world could recast
Mackenzie Davis with Ellen Ellen age 3
dawn of the Ellen song like Ellen
Judgment Day oh you could totally do
that
Ellen the 40-year old Ellen hey Ellen
driver like el driver nice hello
judgement day yeah or nightmare
announcer yeah 28 hours later oh man
everybody hates Ellen Ellen the winter
DeGeneres Ellen Ellen to the Future live
die repeat Ellen of tomorrow the amazing
world of Ellen's I guess we know where
our subscriber base stands and it comes
to Ellen DeGeneres yeah strongly in the
Pro category all right all right it's
time to get some more soup
butcha let's see what's going on super
chats all right what do we got in
reference to my super chef in the
earlier stream I also watched his Sam
for the first time you know fun movie
Shazam thank thank you Tiant a Wimbish
for that Oh
what's your name not enough people talk
about Shazam
it kind of got overshadowed by this
[ __ ] endgame movie I know and it did
moderately well which means it was a
failure
it's a goddamn catastrophe okay we can't
have that no that's what that seems like
a really nice quarantine movie to watch
Shazam no oh yeah that uplift that's a
perfect one had that fun oh absolutely
mm-hmm what's up to David Sandberg I'm
Dion yeah good call there I wish she
caught it in the theaters oh you should
go now it's funny as we watch this
Deonte we watch Shazam for the first
time at an early screening and it was
alright but then when we watched it with
a big crowd and everyone was laughing it
was a great time yeah so now I'm
wondering do I really love that movie
because we saw without a crowd I don't
know when you're not really hearing
everyone laugh with a bunch of people
you're kind of like this must not be
that good yeah but then I don't know
maybe I'm wrong I don't know I mean I
didn't like absolutely love it when I
came out but I was like oh yes that's
true it's true so all right this is me
let's see here oh yeah oh my god well
yeah we're there Eric horseman hey and
this so my BFF can't believe I'm sorry
just starting to drink now gonna do
shots to catch up lol catch up on killin
eve feelin e to contribute Eric you've
contributed plenty enough I appreciate
you doing that buddy
killing Eve I haven't seen killing
evyatar her that's a great show and of
course you're drinking now Eric we
talked about this you gotta cut back on
some of the drinking here he's killing
and cut back on some of the drink it's
killing my liver while I'm watching
Killiney you just got a covetous
elements time to celebrate he's able to
get one at all you know but you know do
you you're the drunkest person I know at
this point I feel like if you stopped
you would go into a media withdrawals my
buddy my buddy do all right let's see
your code all right whoa we got Cedric
yes Cedric Thank You Cedric first time
back to the future
first is my favorite thank you for your
super chat dude and yes I agree with you
first back to the future
my favorite one oh my god look in here
this [ __ ] vienna last name yeah a lot
emir dragon oven is it fixed i think
it's fixed now yeah for an hour and a
half i sure hope it's fixed Anissa
Olivia thank you again my dear Greg you
need to watch Forrest Gump arguably that
is the one movie I should be watching
during quarantine because I've never
seen it but I got an inner geek to match
coming up meaning I'm only gonna be
studying for that after hours and not
appreciate film for the next couple
weeks and then lose my Schmo down match
yes
appreciate the extra super chat anis
that's really sweet of you eventually
he'll see don't worry
new eyes you didn't have to Rican
tribute your super chat dude he said
Ozark Kim's convenience mine hunter
extraction rewatch her to Perdition Coco
hell or high water LA Confidential does
last super chat he did not mention how a
composition it's like when they release
an album with a couple extra songs yeah
that's a good movie - I think LA
Confidential is a film that truly stands
the test of time yeah I think that's
like in like one I think movies that
really stand the test of time are films
that it this is gonna sound like a weird
statement ok Godfather one was made in
I'm gonna be a look like a total dumbass
sir 60 or 70 70s Godfather was made in
the 70s but it takes place during the
40s LA Confidential was made in the 90s
but takes place during the 50s yeah and
I find that those movies are the ones
that tend to stand the test of time not
the ones that are made in the decade
they were that they're actually shot in
but the ones that capture a decade from
earlier like Goodfellas is one I I don't
know what it is about that but it really
seems to work for capturing a different
time or as opposed to a movie in the 50s
feels like a movie in the 50 yeah but
when you capture the 50s from a
different I like it but 90s but we did
it yeah it's it's weird
but I feel like there's a benefit to
that
yeah well coz is yeah there's a
different level of perspective and a
different level of informing you can do
based on all the we know about that past
time right and that does I think also
especially like if it's coming out and
it's a period piece it gives you it just
lends itself to that timelessness you
know yeah that's a good point
yeah it's a good point 223 likes thank
you guys for hitting those like button
man can we do 225 hole ah where's worse
than where's the other line I'm gonna
skim this chat to make sure everyone's
still doing the Ellen talk we're gonna
revisit it in just a minute hold on I
want to make sure we're catching up here
Oh fade of horns I do gotta watch Twin
Peaks for reals maybe that'll be my one
of my quarantine assignments
Ryan Beatty Rizzo gave me thank you to
the negotiator Gladiator Edgar Wright
movie last movie the negotiator those
are great movies to catch up on while
you're in quarantine for sure
negotiators are under a half of a good
not so good one [ __ ] guy oh yeah
that's right I totally forgot I always
think it was Sam Jackson and Paul G of
money did you hear about that gladiator
movie that was supposed to deal with
like Maximus fighting gods and it was
supposed to be like [ __ ] like real
fantasy based this is gonna be like
Clash of the Titans but with Maximus
instead like I remember the screenwriter
who wrote it was like I know this idea
is not going to get approved so I'm just
gonna get all out and sure enough it
wasn't approved wrote the whole
screenplay yeah and I would love to read
yeah I wish more of those would happen
like we used to do a series at the old
cafe I worked out where people would
read on produce scripts and I feel like
those would be like something like that
we absolutely like Beetlejuice goes to
the beach or whatever that sequel script
that was floating around was 100% all
right let's see here we're gonna go back
to Hell and chatter so look how the
chats now just the Ellen chat Samuel
parsley did you like El Camino yuck love
El Camino luck okay so my plan right now
also I really want a skinny Pete and
badger spin-off show about a show but I
watch like a one-off short film or like
or like a few short webisodes
you know like a comic strip this is your
first time being here Samuel parsley I
appreciate being here thanks for the
super chat to you at least I know we've
talked to you today but yeah have you
been here in the past um El Camino I
think is great and I feel like the the
buzz for that died down a little I would
like a direct I like an I mean it was a
dry he cut it however the [ __ ] you
wanted to but I'd like an extended
version of that move because I heard
there's like an hour of footage at last
I used in that film being such a big
Breaking Bad fan I loved it
but my plan is once better call Saul
because they do you my girlfriend hasn't
seen Breaking Bad and I haven't seen
Sopranos so I was like alright tell you
what I'll watch Sopranos by the time I
we finally finished Sopranos I might be
completely done what better call Saul
when its final season comes out so I'll
watch better call Saul right I'm on the
right path être will watch better calls
well I'm gonna finish Brack I'll solve
that I'm an introducer of Breaking Bad
yes and then we'll move on El Camino so
I'm kind of doing this whole like
Breaking Bad over stange experience
ah really that's that's like the most
consistent cinematic universe of them
all is the Breaking Bad birth right now
yeah because also this the attention to
continuity has to be so high so good so
good alright yeah one more Super chair
and a go to the Ellen Jett Eric what a
perfect segue to our an Ellen chat Ellen
DeGeneres said she was vegan oh thank
you for your super today but eats fish
no pun intended
she freaking eat story what and only
English hippo Chris I hate Ellen what a
hypocrite I'll kill her what a hypocrite
guys subscribe to watchmojo.com against
Ellen all right okay this whole chat is
only Ellen titles I [ __ ] love it
I like when people just add Ellen's than
like a play on Ellen okay all right
curse of the Ellen pearl dirty Ellen
dirty Alan $127 Oh No 500 days of Ellen
hmm The Ellen King Ellen's labyrinth the
shape of Ellen oh my god this is the
greatest live stream it happened on
anyone else's live stream this is the
greatest live 600-pound Ellen
no I've hundred days of Ellen my god
which would be better Ellen and Morty or
Rick and Ellen Ellen and Morty a game of
Ellen's Eleanor hi Ellen
Little Miss Ellen what we do in the
Ellen's are that's great oh and Ellen
Ellen the dark world
Lord of the Ellen's Eternal Sunshine of
the spotless Ellen mmm jail Angie
snow-white quiet good call The Ellen
strikes back The Wizard of Ellen Ellen
becomes her death becomes Ellen the Big
Bang Ellen Brokeback Ellen
five feet apart well why'd you retract
this was it too good
yeah what was it Matthew were very you
can't leave us hanging that way oh this
is so good to generous Unchained he is
not silent Oh
- generous unchanged so that is a
masterful 1/ln daddy's here oh that
that's that's a because it also doesn't
hinge on Ellen at all wait way to go way
to sneak in the back door
shouts out Harry Ellen and the Ellen of
Secrets and Ellen is poor oh my god
Ellen into the Ellen
a couple times once upon a dead le the
incredible Ellen alright one Ellen okay
here we go alright we're gonna we're
gonna go back to that we're gonna this
is gonna mean all Ellen podcasts from
now on Anisa liver John let's go to a
tame impala concert together
sounds nice no concerts exist at the
moment but when they start touring that
new record again
thank you for your Chinese motorcycle us
that's a great badass attitude I mean
can you have multiple key of the same
usernames on YouTube because motorcycle
us is a [ __ ] great ass username that
sounds like a channel that should be
dedicated to american-made cycles he
says I closed it out my bad what I'm
done
rewatched heavy metal blue rape badass
soundtrack I'm happy for you in heavy
metal I'm happy for you though I've seen
bits and pieces of heavy metal what was
it like what you saw was so good it was
really uh I haven't seen it but thanks
for the recommendation
heavy metal and barbed wire mixed up
alright bernis panners great question do
you guys roommate together no mask
distance sorry if that's known I don't
see Austin Ames and John looks like
brutal moose now the rules of the stay
at home orders in California are no more
than 10 people in a house and I have a I
don't have a house I have a condo all
right it's a rent a condo rent a condo
just me and my girlfriend John lives at
home with about four people there if you
count himself there and then there's me
and my girlfriend here we don't bring
anyone else over so like that my family
came over and we even kept a distance
there so based off of the guideline
rules and I made sure to really read
this whole thing through we're not
breaking any guidelines here yeah we're
essentially the the people I get close
to include you yeah and my family
members like there are other channels
I've seen where they're still meeting up
and that's because they're still within
guideline parameters but no very anal
about who comes over or if they
man and yeah but appreciate you asking
that dude Lee station gaming thank you
for your super chat dude the first
spider-man movie is the best movie come
at me bro practical effects awesome
villain and just the best paced movie I
mean we'll do it I don't want to come at
you because I could get in trouble for
attacking you in public
yeah I mean I would I'd whoop your ass
I'm just saying I'm more powerful than
you in every way so if you ever see me
in public
try it I still think it's spider-man 2 I
would that's my personal favorite but
hey if you have a song if you have a
major spot in your heart for spider-man
1 I'm not gonna complain it you do I do
love that first spider-man movie I don't
know if it's my faves but I'll back you
up a bit thank you for your super
chassis and Weston Mayor do you guys
have zoomed for patreon with love chat
love ciao Weston preciate super chapel
with love Chad we're gonna get you're
gonna get kinky with us Weston hello
there are you gonna does you gonna love
chat with us because obviously I might
be down for the dude hop into my HP love
chat response I want to every joke so
good that was that felt great
Ethan whole gay thank you buddy have you
heard of Irish sitcom father father Ted
that to ethan hawke okay to have heard
of Irish sitcom father Ted I think I've
even seen one episode but not enough to
expound ahead and I'm sorry I mean I
feel bad when we get super chance like
that and I can't really elaborate I
haven't met me
but knowing here's all say Ethan because
you brought it up someone's gonna ask me
in a couple days about a show called
father Ted mm-hmm and then I'm like
that's so funny so embroidered up that's
the way my life goes with every show
like the Alex Garland show I've had five
people bring that show up to me this
week oh my god even watching devs devs
is like the number one most talked-about
show to me this week
also to zoom have like a special patreon
input I don't know that's a good thing
to look into furnace we we didn't we
didn't miss it we just answered it yeah
this was a long time ago that's true
Eric horseman he's jumping in on the gay
talk verdict with the gates
oh my god that's how much behind we are
yeah oh my god it just uploaded why are
we always so my Eric says try not to
confuse people here yeah alright what's
going on all right
goddamnit like I got it but I gotta yes
I got it
all right I'm gay hey drag race Oh drag
race is not about gear racing it's it's
a show about uh it's about it's a show
about people who race but they're
dragging somebody behind them you gotta
see who gets to the finish line first
you know dragging another human rather
watch my toenails grow if Greg says this
it says this in a gay cliche accent I'm
a flapper [ __ ] kidding you do you Greg
you know I love you and John - I love
you too Eric I'm sorry drag race is not
a great show for you my homosexual
friend but there are some gay people and
stray people who apparently really liked
that show not all gay people think the
same this is a case in point I'm glad we
could clear that up though but do you
hate RuPaul that's what I want to know
how do you feel about RuPaul all right
all right RuPaul I'm really tempted to
go back to the Ellen chat because I love
the [ __ ] out of that Widow you know we
can always revisit it I think maybe do
one more oh man we've done a trilogy
visit in a while I know we got a revisit
a trailer guys which Ellen's rulership
there we go this looks a lot cleaner
a much nicer image a black blur to put
here while you're reading the the black
box black box when we arrived thank you
for your super cat again Eric
Colby Franklin what's up dude
he says hey guys just got my wisdom
teeth taken out
spongebob squarepants is still the best
show I mean it's so good I mean how
could you not love spongebob
so imagine Erewhon toxin you know John
won't you happen unless you love
spongebob watch tell him how much you
know spongebob is a show that I actually
was able to elect the cartoons out there
it's one of the few TV show experiences
I vividly remember for being able to
anticipate before it was coming I was
like they're waiting for the premiere
and then I was all a bit like I was
right there for the perfect moment and
and yeah it's like I haven't watched as
much spongebob lately but every now and
again I need a few episodes especially
you know like one of the old faves or
something like that like the one with
Nosferatu I've got a big love for that
episode fair enough man yeah yeah I love
the spongebob I got to catch up with the
most recent two movies but uh yeah I'm a
big big big big fan of Bob gonna miss
Steve Hillenburg appreciate that super
shot there buddy that way John has a
chance to talk yeah Bob a sponge ah
Esplanade all right where we at next
where it where yes they at that time in
the stream where Greg gets hungry
look Jill level TV are you guys excited
for HBO max if so why I'm not gonna lie
man I HP Oh max has not been seeming all
that exciting to me lately I'm having
intense deja vu right now I'm just more
like why what's wrong
I just feel like we've had this I feel
like I've lived this moment before what
do you mean I don't know for some reason
talking about well now it's yeah broken
the matrix now but I mean
what's I mean HBO max has not really
done the best job at promoting itself
yeah they started I'm bailing like
actual trailers for [ __ ] it was like
alright well yeah I think they're in a
weird position because they've had HBO
go and now for a long time and they were
you know one of the early adopters of
like here's our streaming app that you
could just log into from your cable or
whatever I mean so it just seems like
another HP like it's not doing enough to
really I'm excited for it in the sense
of we might get the Snyder cutoff there
but that's about the main thing that
gets me excited yeah
that possibility yeah I feel like a lot
of us are already on board for HBO app
and a lot of us already have HBO app so
like HBO max doesn't seem as much like
an event I think as it could or some and
are they gonna euthanize HBO now when
max comes out as HBO now is the
standalone version of HBO GO
well no I'm not that I said but thanks
for your question chill level TV curious
for it Erik horsemen thanks for being
behind I'm now caught up on drinking all
the way to totally wasted my liver
thanks to you don't [ __ ] thank me for
that Erica I feel bad I got wasted quick
well Erik probably just [ __ ] probably
wrote that like some kind of competition
meant for five people just on his own
I gotta stop doing that Jon I know it's
okay don't I'm just trying not to
confuse people here zoom in a little bit
on that bad boy no no no this is better
look at this look now it's like right
now it's more it's more geometric and
Nisa so happy I gotta talk to you when
you two was down and getting the
behind-the-scenes Greg you are my
favorite person in the world
John is too she said me first I know the
tables are turning we're going to have
to fight Anissa and heesu
John what John John Oh John
but butthole
yes thanks your hand more super chat yes
as always to you we're gonna do three
more super chats and then go back to the
Ellen chat which is what most
undoubtedly is is it still the Ellen
chats to Ellen Ellen stole Christmas
it's already gone playing with it I love
it [ __ ] love it
alright I was happy to talk to you too
Aneesa Michael B what's up buddy Omni
media again went back to Hannibal dude I
know you went back to apples you not
read my patreon message I see you posing
on Stardust you appreciate the super
show went back to Hannibal per your
recommendation and I'm home well I do
now I'm only two more episodes left as
well I've been watching animal during
quarantine and soon terms of the
original the original theme hmm
just watch Logan lucky no idea took
place in weava West Virginia I'm smart
and [ __ ] smart it was so accurate I
mean if dude if it's gonna be [ __ ]
Steven Soderbergh directing yeah he's
gonna go for accuracy Ocean's Twelve so
real yeah Julia Roberts
well damn I'm glad you're enjoying
Hannibal seems like you're enjoying it
for the five-year-old if you're only two
episodes left and I'm glad that you it's
always nice and you recommend something
and that someone really feels like
they've benefited off of the
recommendation so thank you Michael B
you're really sweet Newman lowly lucky
is pretty good yeah random Andy's
channel has some has has some Ellen is
Ellen's it's the perfect sag if you're
randomly tuning into here I brought up a
question let me clear this up if you're
just randomly tuning in now first off
hit the like button secondly it's that
it's cuz I I said to the chat randomly
do you guys think Ellen's a fraud
because I've been seeing random videos
going on
about her and now this whole chat is all
of people using their creative side of
their brain to come up with Ellen
DeGeneres titles about the villainous
Ellen so I'm not so villainous one-punch
Ellen and Sheldon no we have random
andis channel thank you for your super
chat dude oh my god John I did it again
how could you all right here's we're
gonna do John yeah John John John
what'd it do John you going back to the
mustache
now here's what a dim alright hold on a
sec okay any of fix this yeah and they
fix this you got the losing viewers
I believe we're losing viewers by the
second John what are you looking for I
just a banner well I'm looking for a
banner of Bruce Banner matter of a
matter of manner Bruce Banner or banner
a Bruce Banner there we go let's just
assume ooh speaking of Bruce Banner I
just watched a movie and Quarantine
starring Mark Ruffalo called dark waters
was very funny and uplifting all about
the DuPont chemical situation but it was
it was quality was good movie was it Oh
John what did I do hit back you can't
just drop it in cuz Italy nah I think I
broke YouTube again guys I'm sorry
that's it John all bets are off
yeah no dark waters man like it's
completely mad it's one of those movies
that and this would be a good topic for
the future I think it's one of those
movies it's not a horror movie but
especially once you they start to unfold
the actual situation at hand it becomes
a very tense and sinister dramatic
experience and yeah it's fascinating
fascinating and a great reminder of the
fact that often times we think people
are watching over stuff and they aren't
and you know that we got all look out
for each other because you know big
entities aren't necessarily going to do
that so yeah and it was really well
acted to
I appreciate you giving your revered
dark waters we we lost 25 years I am so
sorry um market ruffalo the Hulk did I
mention he's dr. Hulk the whole movie oh
my god then we got the jaws so good look
at this setup damn John I [ __ ] it up
all right you're gonna do good all right
Alan her rear window 'ln Cinderella new
Cinderella that works really well so
does Eleanor I really like those do a
lot thank you thank you random and his
channel that's great appreciate you
submitting Brendan V thank you buddy who
would you have portray Carrie martyr
white and Castle Rock Oh John come on
give an answer who would you would you
have portrayed Carrie martyr white in
Castle Rock um maybe I would give it to
showman Fallon or I would give it to the
lady in what's her name she's in all the
seasons of American Horror Story and the
first season she's the older version of
the maid she's Arthur flex mom yeah I'm
a penny dreadful yes I might cast one of
them as a Margaret as a Carrie tricky
right now I mean I before when they were
remaking it the first time I would have
said abigail breslin but for now yes
Suzanne Hamill that's Mark Hamill's mom
I said who plays Arthur flex mom on
Google and it gave me Francisco yes so I
cast her and then maybe you know who I
think would be an interesting choice is
if you got the little girl from
hereditary yeah that's me to play Carrie
be good well that's cool mm-hmm
all right here we at Thank You Brendan V
Aneesa Thank You Aneesa supernatural
show its final seven episodes this fall
in the CW and it's super sad every game
close to the end so
a good show such great cast you know
worries me about the fact that they you
know worries me about the fat
supernaturals ending I wonder if once
it's over all of our patrons who are
were there for supernatural gonna lose
interest in what we're doing I wonder
not that they're all rear watching it
now thanks for the anxiety attack right
now and ISA know the show's done I don't
need to revisit the earlier anymore I
mean that's that's kind of my worry with
that with covering you know all right
you know we'll always have Doctor Who
random Andy's channel that swinger
lifestyle sounds fun oh god no no you
don't want the swingers lifestyle Randy
stick to your guns wait till marriage
that's the safest bet you will regret it
sex does not feel as good as people
think it does no it doesn't taste like
beer isn't taste good like you think it
will so I'm just trying to keep you
going do you come this far you you're
you seem really buff because you haven't
done it yet so please keep it go keep it
up man
I want to meet somebody who's waiting
til after divorce - what - have sex John
about Robert Pattinson we could if
Robbie Hanson has sex without we could
be a movie sex all right Ellen's day off
- in peeks Ellen walk with me the Ellen
which brush Oh II so okay I mean we can
see that oh we can see right here hey
it's a good thing I accidentally close
this window up when Ellen meet met
Anissa no yeah Ellen a Star Wars story
simple simple wins the race and Ellen
day in the neighborhood
we'll get to the super chat don't worry
Donny dark Ellen open your Ellen The
Ellen rejects like that
the real DeGeneres shelvings 12:01 bunch
Ellen is so good there's something about
Ellen is that's a great one mm-hmm
now this live version even got bit sure
Ellen movie and I know Ellen day - you
eat prey Ellen that's a good one
punch-drunk Ellen Ellen of the galaxy
Ellen L music to be harassed
oh god Ellen cemetery the Battlestar
Galactica with the Ellen ship of the
Ring Diary of a Wimpy Ellen thank you
guys for doing this sorry to bother
outlet alright don't be an Ellen while
drinking your spritzer in Montecito
thank you for that don't be a menace
reference all right Eric horseman thank
you for your super chat duty he's saying
that for his Cova 19 test he sucked the
swabs of both nostrils and they hit my
freaking brain swirled 20 seconds in
each not a great feeling was totally
tearing up will get results in about
three days
that sounds really painful that's I
didn't know how painful these covert
tests works until Eric just said that
that sounds really awful this is not the
first time I've heard somebody use that
exact description of like they touched
my freaking brain so yeah that's I think
is good enough incentive as anybody
needs to try and uphold our part of the
quarantine and stuff because I don't
want to have 40 seconds of invasive nose
swabbing that sounds [ __ ] gross are
you touching my favorite it sounds so
unpleasant and I'm getting phantom pain
just just imagining it I'm glad you got
your test man and please let me know
your results Eric please message me a
message we do hope that comes back
negative so that it's positive news
Mykleby says caught up on better call
Saul thank you for a super chat dude
preciate it caught up on better call
Saul and thank you Eric for the last one
- Cobham better call saul kong wars
mando die for that mando documentary is
really good all of DC TV go to his
youtube channel Omni media watch his
reactions and reviews with mortal combat
scorpions represent
revenge and Justice League dark
apocalypse I've heard Justice League
dark apocalypse is great
yeah I gotta watch that [ __ ] man I've
heard that's amazing do these everything
you've just wash her it's everything I
really want to catch up on that I
haven't caught up on but I've heard that
man no documentaries really good it's
not an emergency awesome video breakdown
in one of the episodes it was the one
where Dave Filoni was talking about the
importance of that duel of the fates
fight scene in Episode one and it really
did paint that that fight in a
completely different light to me I was
like actually I now appreciate episode 1
because of how Dave Filoni pitched yeah
yeah there you go
everybody hailed the Fulani ri is the
one person people dressed okay
Brendan V Sain thoughts on the Scream
reboot thank you for your super chat
Brendan I'm hopeful optimistic after
hearing who the directors are if you
guys are knows the directors from ready
or not plus I really want to be in it to
be honest as the rani type character he
gets killed off in a cool way
ah we all whoa and Randy is ready and
Randy is us we love Randy [ __ ] love
Randy um I don't I don't know I mean I'm
not a big fan of scream for I think a
lot of people believe it really went out
on a high note I'm not a big fan of
scream for I like it I don't love it
have you seen scream for know Jesus John
it's supposed to be the horror but watch
it tonight tomorrow you guys stay for
Saturday dumb maybe there's a scream
category John you're expected to do a
good job I know I'm expecting on be fun
in my star I mean like there's a big
difference I know and I'm gonna be
pounded let's see the thing is you know
I have a lot of Harry Potter and in Lord
of the Rings built up in my subconscious
I'm gonna have to go and rekindle some
of that obviously the Star Wars stuff
I'm be studying from here until the yeah
you think no more I'll show you wild
guys didn't I like your Tim Burton hair
well I think the scream reboot the
scream reboot I don't know I mean Neve
Campbell I hear is being courted for
it Ellen isn't scream I hear I hear Neve
Campbell's being courted for it she
hasn't agreed to it she talked candidly
about how she's like she likes the
directors and what they're planning but
I don't know I mean to do it without Wes
Anderson I know the show was was fairly
received well wasn't received well and I
feel like you can continue to scream
world it's just like if he could bring
like Ghostface back in there and Sidney
Prescott's toured it just seems like
words we're done now yeah you know yeah
and there's not much more you can do
with that unless you like fo gets hurt
Sidney into the killer well yeah because
the thing is that the slasher movie is
not the prevalent horror sub-genre right
now and so I feel like a new scream what
either have to really not only be meta
but also reinvent or not not only be
meta but also like reinvent or bring
something new to that genre or branch
out to broader horror because that's you
know the the DNA of those movies is
deconstruction and so you know just
making one to make one seems like a
particularly point exactly yeah i don't
know i'm not i'm not exactly i'm like
you dude i'm hopeful optimistic for it
but i really don't know yeah pj i fell
behind on the stream but i caught back
up pj are my initials you can call me
Paul if you want although pandemic Jones
works - well thanks PJ appreciate your
superjet dearly appreciate the end for
now on you will be pandemic Jonah June's
alright let's see what's here bad boys
for Ellen hell yeah is great bad boys
for Ellen Helen yeah
Greg speaks Spanish go molest us love
the locks Greg well it now it's gonna
get beyond lock this is gonna get
[ __ ] banana sandwich I would once
know one and I have one small I'm a man
of the Nights Watch Oh
somebody cut Wes Anderson does scream I
regret I would love to see Wes Anderson
scream dawn of the Planet of the Ellen's
five nights and Ellen's that's a great
one Ellen and hood yeah Ellen in scream
five the Ellen Network can we also do
spec Co in the next string that'd be fun
comment about actually the prequels now
are we getting prequel loves that was
you Ellen to hand our mughelli Mr
McGowan that's great Matthews to you
that's great yes Ellen the tank has a
fantastic human she's the best far from
that Selma and Ellen Ice Age collision
Ellen Ellen and Louise house of a
thousand aliens the beauty of the Ellen
yeah I'm beginning to feel like a rap
god rap god all my people from the front
to the back not all right sama parsley
think he did it is his first time here
he's watching better call Saul [ __ ] yeah
man better call Saul is a great show
seriously watch while you're here once
you're caught up I'm better call Saul
that Oh a lot the latest season finale
that was yeah tax I'll tell you all
right guys we're gonna wrap this up in a
little bit I'm getting way too nice
Oliver back at it again have you all
ever seen stop-loss with Channing Tatum
if not I was in that movie when I was
little remember by the bus check out my
two seconds of fame is that to the to
the list Anissa nobody told us you were
a movie hard hey Matt I mean yeah damn
it's pretty big did you get to me
Channing
did you get to Channing to Tatum I'm
trying to give the viewers of a really
high goal this is taken all right okay
this should be the reactions for now on
imagine watch watch watch
[Music]
hmm it's easy to read this way alright
so we will watch the entire movie of
stop loss and hope we can catch you in
there and then we'll make a 10-hour
super cut of your moment
thanks for the name praise watch og
heavy metal good motorcycle us thanks
for the super chat buddy we've got a
great name glad you took it tells ya
Joshua TIG TIG huh
love your channel guys keep up the great
work Joshua Teague I love your name yeah
how this isn't a genuine moment of that
I hope or perhaps you know Jon why did
you why are you not doing the thing
what's your name is no I'm talking about
your [ __ ] hair see Jon gets all of
his pride and glory from his
good-looking hair you cut that off he's
nothing up and that's why he wants to
make sure he looks good yeah Ben Brady
braiding it at night though cuz it's
many in the summertime so chaotic we
look like two ragged dolls Hank you know
yeah Thank You Joshua Teague and a nice
L live up thank you my dear you always
the best ways to close out our live
streams do y'all speak Spanish if so say
something that Lois funny because I live
in a mexican-american family took four
years of Spanish and is there nothing I
don't speak Spanish I don't speak
Spanish but I do know some swear words
in Tagalog bouton ye na mo that means
son of a [ __ ] Bhutan ye na mo Tonga
means stupid these are words my mother
would call me and John Dean or Spanish
soy un perdedor also do you know did you
hear about the Percy Jackson TV series
no more super chest ultra wallet okay
did you hear about the Percy Jackson
there's an angel about to get its way I
have not heard about the first Jackson
TVs I'm I'm sure it'll be good I'm sure
Logan Lerman returning that we got some
I would hope so but probably not is
brandon t Jackson and Theresa my god or
who is the female Rizzo gaming no I'm
trying to I want to thank you buddy
I appreciate your super chat Sinisa
appreciate I just loved you a nisa Rizzo
gaming Greg order takeout if you're
hungry damn it yeah I don't want to
order take it I want to make sure I'm
cooking from home as much as possible
being responsible one session with the
way the economy's shaping out to be to
try to make sure that like you know I'm
just being as docile as possible it's
just hell it's healthier right now that
I eat that we eat from home especially
because I mean I got used to the gym
lifestyle going there like four to five
days a week and now there's no gym I
have to eat even healthier because
there's no gym so yeah that was easier
to maintain a certain weight now I'm
like really I've actually lost some
weight during this uh during this
pandemic not like skinny but I'm almost
there well there you go that's all you
needed was the pandemic regimen Oh Rizzo
I love your next I love your next Super
chat thank you dude he says he says
please your best Chewie with hair like
that sounds like a very sick Chewie no
guys don't don't compete don't compete
yeah guys just it's okay I need to
please no don't do that don't do it you
two love each other
I appreciate the joke you you are you
are so supportive
I was also it's also an excess no I'm
feeling bad about your patreon country
hey no no guys no we want don't don't
want to love thank you don't compete
Jasmin love you too let's read some of
these Ellen chats and then we're gonna
properly read off the last couple super
chats here
Ellen [ __ ] I can't see anything ah Star
Wars Ellen special rizzo gaming fam
joke's on you all right Eric and Aneesa
it's time for you to compete oh great
one v Ellen May
that's great that's a good all hey
that's the greatest compliment anyone's
paid me look like Rob Zombie take it if
I have that uh if I could grow my beard
longer who do I look like an Ewok a
little bit you guys it's good I like it
all of your burden you hear Megillah
Ellen dawn oh that's great you know
speaking of those movies I just watched
in a silent movie plus atlantic rim yeah
Ellen Downey jr. oh very good
don't [ __ ] it up set today Ellen a
perjurer Persia Chronicles of Ellen
that'd be great if we went on The Ellen
Show next week if they were just like I
saw your live stream and how much it was
dedicated to that so what's your problem
with three from Ellen three Star Wars
The Ellen special Saving Private Ellen
okay
Greg you look like Dan avidan from ninja
sex party better call Ellen Saving
Private good I look like a homeless
person is what it says all right
all right let's root the last of these
super chats yes the last of us to
everyone's favorite new game I'm last as
always if this is the last Annie sent
Eric I'm saying this right now thank you
for your super chats the multiples that
I can already see previewing here
appreciate it
I'm last as always this is the last and
then you can say I'm closing this [ __ ]
out Greg and John looking like the ring
girl best call we definitely do I look
like he looks like the ring girl
I look like if the ring girl was like
the Middle East reboot appreciate that
buddy and he's Eric you want to go
fabulous step it in like that so fun I
mean I'm on Aneesa love you are you guys
Jake thank you for prying my day guys No
thank you guys writing up our days we
love doing these live streams really do
thank you guys and chill level TV we do
have weekly podcasts on our patreon page
is only for the dollar pledge so if you
want to do that go there chill uh
they do a podcast on the patreon thanks
for catching queue and nice effort for
catching that for us you're so sweet
she level-2 who thinks an extra super
chat buddy and no okay competitions over
I'm putting that too right now sing the
Doctor Who theme that's me and Aneesa
everybody wants to compete now nope you
won the competition unfair make patreon
free I don't think you quite understand
unfair my patreon free there's this
old-fashioned concept called direct
patronage or people who cared about what
you made just paid directly for reason
you know you're doing with that super
chat dude you're you're stoking this
fire you're making your super job I do
you guys are so funny and I love it you
guys are all scary
Ellen stories nice Oh winds make patreon
cheaper it's a dollar or five I mean
it's a dollar
we have various tiers but for one or
five dollars you can get a lot of
content and I'll say the content that we
offer for a five is cheaper than the
other patrons who offer similar content
so I think we're being I really think
we're being as fair in the middle ground
as possible we have a growing $5 of
video it's fun for the month you get the
entire log of our stream alongs and
stuff like we don't have a live schedule
we just kind of decide at the beginning
of the week yeah
sort of like alright Eddie
and this livestream before this gets
outta hand you guys I need to be doing
oh my god fun but but I want to make
sure okay
and you say and I make sure everybody's
reading these yeah I needs to stop
really lol this is the funny [ __ ] okay I
need to seriously get the reject Kahn
love you and last word no no okay thank
you guys for being so fun and supportive
and having this friendly competition
Aneesa gets the last word
there it is I appreciate all the super
chats you guys have contributed I love
all the Ellen titles that have come in
here too fast too well this is great I
hope you guys hope for the most part
enjoyed the this weird chaotic live
stream that did this I mean this is one
of our weirdest ones we've done for sure
you guys have been insanely sweet
insanely generous John what he doing
alright and Aneesa is not rich she's we
give her the money to give in this
livestream to encourage other people I
love you all but but no more again this
is that everyone's done appreciate you
guys you guys are so sweet I'm gonna let
it needs to be the last one we're gonna
click out Samuel appreciate you coming
in Ryan baby everyone here you guys have
been so incredibly kind love love the on
titles I will be reviewing them much
love
hey take care have a great day peace
this is a lot of fun thank you this is
love you guys thank you
Nisa you one Erik second place Ryan
third
[Music]